on en vient à ce drame de la
Saint-Vincent près de Chinon 1500
personnes étaient rassemblées ce samedi
à Cravant les coteaux pour l'une des
plus grandes fêtes viticoles de la
région faite endeuillée par la mort d'un
septuagénaire mortellement renversé par
un bus à fêter pour l'événement
Romainville
aggravant les coteaux la fête de la
Saint-Vincent 2023 étant donné il était
aux alentours de 21h35 du soir Quentin
des sicards a fêté pour faire la tournée
des caves de la commune renverse Michel
Ricottier un cravanté septuagénaire qui
participait plutôt au festivités avec
des membres de sa famille
l'accident tragique s'est déroulé au
niveau du lieu-dit narcé sur la
départementale 21 dans des circonstances
qu'il reste encore à éclaircir l'enquête
a été confiée à la gendarmerie de Chinon
toutes les mesures de sécurité sont
anticipées aussi bien par les
organisateurs que par la municipalité
pour apporter confort et sécurité aux
participants et j'insiste là dessus les
bus sont affectés de façon à ce que les
gens puissent partir du chapitre visiter
les caves en bus uniquement en bus et
seulement
aussitôt que la gravité de l'accident a
été connue par la mairie et le comité
d'organisation les festivités de la 62e
édition ont été stoppés et les convives
priez de rentrer chez eux après le
buffet après deux ans d'absence la plus
grande fête de la Saint-Vincent en Val
de Loire 1500 convives y participer se
terminant drame tout se passait très
bien le spectacle Les d'un seul coup la
fête ça a été interrompu d'un seul coup
on était donc sur les lieux et on a pris
la sage décision avec Monsieur le Maire
de d'arrêter la fête immédiatement en
légende pour au chapiteau qui s'alimente
avec de l'eau pour qu'ils reconduisent
leur voiture et repartir gentiment et
tout était stoppé
naturellement depuis une dizaine
d'années l'écart assuré une plus grande
sécurité autour de l'événement pour la
Saint-Vincent 2024 si elle a lieu le
comité d'organisation annule la tournée
traditionnelle des caves et les
participants resteront sous le chapiteau